en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y los acompaño desde casa por la
situación causada por el cob y 19
iniciamos hablando del impacto que la
pandemia ha tenido en mujeres
embarazadas un macro análisis que
incluye 40 estudios con 6 millones de
embarazadas de 17 países muestra que
durante el último año se produjo un
incremento en las muertes de gestantes
más complicaciones durante el embarazo o
la muerte del feto dentro del útero esto
no significa que el coi 19 decido
puntualmente la causa de esos problemas
los expertos los llaman efectos
colaterales debido a que muchas mujeres
en su temor por contagiarse no
asistieron a los controles adecuados a
tiempo y en casos de urgencia tardaron
demasiado en pedir ayuda la profesora de
asma khalil una obstetra del hospital
saint george de londres explica lo que
se vivió durante la primera cuarentena
en la capital británica la zona de
triage he estado así en comparación a
cómo estaría normalmente con muchas
mujeres en ese momento había muy poca
había una presentación retrasada para
análisis y las mujeres que tenían a sus
bebés no se desplazaban mucho preferían
llamar a su médico oa su parte era en
lugar de unir al hospital realmente
estaban preocupadas y decían esperaré
hasta mañana el informe publicado en la
revista médica the lancet halló que el
número de bebés que murieron dentro del
útero aumentó en casi un tercio durante
la pandemia la misma proporción de
mujeres que fallecieron por
complicaciones estando embarazadas por
otra parte el número de gestantes que
necesitaron atención de urgencia por
embarazos ectópicos que se presentan
cuando el bebé crece fuera del útero se
incrementó seis veces más en la pandemia
respecto al año anterior la
investigación cita a los centros para el
control y prevención de enfermedades de
eeuu que exponen que las mujeres
embarazadas tienen mayor riesgo de que
el contagio de kobe 19 genere síntomas
graves que las que no están encinta otro
punto clave es el incremento en el
estrés y la ansiedad de las gestantes y
schering contra jojoy durante su
embarazo su hijo nació sin problemas
pero relata los difíciles momentos de
ser
fue muy estresante en principio pensaba
que tenía neumonía estaba muy preocupada
por el desarrollo del bebé
luego nos enteramos que era con una
virus un gran mundo desconocido eso me
llevó al límite
y estuve demasiado estresada durante el
final de mi embarazo porque pensaba en
cosas que podrían pasarle al bebé
otro punto que resalta el macroestudio
es que las mujeres que además de estar
embarazadas tienen antecedentes de otras
enfermedades como diabetes obesidad o
hipertensión corren un riesgo mayor de
desarrollar síntomas graves y se
contagian por ello los expertos reiteran
la importancia de asistir a controles
periódicos y buscar ayuda de
profesionales a tiempo
seguimos hablando de kobe 19 pero ahora
nos centramos en cuba porque científicos
de este país han fabricado en tiempo
récord equipos e insumos para hacerle
frente a la pandemia entre los aparatos
están ventiladores y entre los insumos
varios componentes de las pruebas pcr
que en principio tuvieron que ser
importados pero ahora significan un
importante avance y ahorro para esa
nación el desarrollo de equipos y
tecnologías médicas nos permite lograr
soberanía en muchos aspectos como lo que
ustedes han visto y también en el
diagnóstico de la cob y 19 otros objetos
producidos por el sector biotecnológico
y farmacéutico son hisopos para la toma
de muestras diarias kits para la
detección de posibles sospechosos
respiradores artificiales no invasivos y
equipos para medir la capacidad pulmonar
además del desarrollo de sus propias
candidatas a vacuna soberana 2 y abdalá
que están en la fase más avanzada de
ensayos y ya hacen parte de estudios de
intervención controlada
lo que estamos sometidos la situación
que tenemos el país no hubiera sido muy
difícil realmente tener los resultados
que estamos teniendo tener en el combate
a la pandemia si no hubiéramos contado
con esta industria que se ha creado la
se maneja de 35 años nuestro país
dejamos el como vid y nos vamos a
francia para conocer una aplicación de
transporte que únicamente trabaja con
vehículos híbridos que generan un
porcentaje de contaminación mucho menor
al de autos de gasolina o diésel se
llama south south y funciona con coches
fabricados en china muy amplios y en su
apariencia similares a los taxis
londinenses la aplicación inició sus
operaciones en china en 2015 y
actualmente cuenta con unos 30 millones
de usuarios en ese país lo que la ubica
como la primera plataforma de vehículos
con conductor allí desde 2019 empezó a
funcionar en parís y ofrece un servicio
premium seguro elegante y responsable
con el medio ambiente
nos centramos en parís primero porque es
una capital económica a nivel de europa
y segundo parís es uno de los primeros
destinos mundiales de turismo aunque
este no es el mejor momento sabemos que
los turistas van a volver a parís y
nuestro werner y finalizamos en china
con el festival internacional de luces
de beijing una muestra de luces de alta
tecnología que permite una experiencia
inmersiva para los visitantes
la instalación llamada a despertar
cuenta con 19 tipos diferentes de
equipos de iluminación que incluyen más
de 12 mil bombillos a ustedes gracias
por acompañarme en este espacio los
invito a visitar nuestra web france24
puntocom para repetir este y otros
programas
[Música]